Was bisher geschah?
By the way on the computer. Jedes Verbrechen lässt sich einfach mit reiner PS lösen. Reaktionstest, Assoziation, Baum. Äh, Faum. Der Van, Estrich und Modelberatung, Marquardt. Natürlich bin ja wieder Shakespeare befangen. Mein Fuß schleift ein, weil ich meinen Schuh zu eng zugebunden habe. Ein letztes Mal zurück zu Shakespeare. Einen trockenen Aal geben, einen trockenen Aal geben. Jetzt alle? Einen trockenen Aal geben. Ich grüsse auch jeden Hund. 9-11 was an Inside-Job. Oh, sag, kannst du sehen. Das Podcast UFO. Hey, hallo und herzlich willkommen zu dieser neuen Ausgabe von Das Podcast UFO.
Mir gegenüber sitzt natürlich wie immer bereit für diese Folge.
Kann es kaum erwarten, aber wann sagt er das erste Wort?
Wann sagt er das erste Wort?
Wie immer sitzt gegenüber von mir fucking Florentin im Welt.
Nein, ich freue mich doch, das ist doch, nein, das ist doch eine gewisse Beständigkeit, ist doch was Schönes.
Genauso beständig wie die tollen Intros, die wir bekommen.
Vielen, vielen Dank für dieses Intro an Tom, Sabine, Gregor, Daniele, Bianca, Lisa, Christian, Max und Peter, die uns dieses fantastische Intro zur Verfügung gestellt haben. Du bist neben meiner Familie die beständigste Person in meinem Leben. Das möchte ich nur mal sagen. Ist das nicht schön? Ja, du nicht ganz, aber ... Fuck you. Mit wem arbeitest du länger zusammen? Gut, mit Lassi-Darich-Pausen arbeitest du wahrscheinlich noch länger zusammen? Nein, aber absolut. Ne, doch. Also ich freue mich auch jede Woche, die ... Also, ne, der Podcast geht los. Ne, ich wollte jetzt gar nicht in diese Ecke. Sorry, wir ... Drängen und so. Okay, ne, also ... Warum, wir können auch private Sachen besprechen hier und er, ich weiß nicht, warum das so. Aber wir haben auch witzige Mails bekommen. Ja, okay. Und aber ... Ich meine nur, es ist doch auch schön. Nein, das ist ja auch okay. Andere Podcasts feiern ihre Jubiläen auch. Bei mir sagst du immer, nee, pack die Luftballons, kannst du wieder zurückbringen. Hast du die Quittung noch? Feier gerne 347, bitte. Ja, mein Gott. Wir sind halt mittendrin gerade irgendwo. Wir sind halt weder vom einen Ufer noch zum anderen. Letzte Woche war Valentinstag. Ja. Ich hab nichts von dir bekommen.
Ich wusste nicht, dass dir der Tag wichtig ist.
Nee, ist nicht wichtig.
Ich dachte, wir sind eher so, dass jeder Tag was wichtig ist.
Patronischer Podcast.
Auch, aber ich dachte eher, du bist eher so ein Typ,
dass jeder Tag wichtig ist.
Ja, nee, ich häng mich jetzt auf ...
Sorry, ich wusste nicht, dass du da was erwartet hast.
Ja, das war jetzt gar nicht ...
Aber ist ja auch nicht so schlimm.
Aber ja. Okay.
Ähm ... Mir ist was richtig Witziges passiert diese Woche. Aber uns ist beiden schon lange nichts mehr Witziges passiert, muss man wirklich auch mal sagen. Kaum was. Nee, weil es ist gerade nicht so witzig. Ich habe das Gefühl, die Erde hat sich so ein bisschen Spaß beiseite gerade. Die Erde hat Spaß beiseite gerade. Andere Probleme, andere Probleme. Du, seit Pluto raus ist, habe ich irgendwie das Gefühl im Sonnensystem. Ich hatte das Gefühl, Pluto war so der Comic Relief irgendwie so. Der ganz, des ganzen Sonnensystems. Und seitdem Pluto raus ist, seitdem der abgehauen ist oder so, hat der mittlerweile was Neues gefunden eigentlich. Das ist so wie so ein Freundeskreis, wo dann eine Figur, macht dann irgendwie ein Auslandsjahr oder sowas, und dann ist die raus und man merkt, ah nee, er hat uns zusammengehalten. Ja. Er war derjenige, weswegen wir uns getroffen haben, er hat abends gefragt, was macht ihr? Genau. Manchmal hängen so Freundeskreise und eine gute Zeit dementsprechend an einer Person. Ja. Das ist Pluto, seit wenn Pluto raus ist. Pluto raus, vor allem jetzt ist Pluto raus, Saturn habe ich jetzt auch gehört, überlegt sich auch, ob er gehen will. Wie, mit welcher Begründung das denn? Ja hat gesagt, es passiert irgendwie nichts mehr. Pluto hat sich als Zwergplanet dann irgendwann verabschiedet. Was macht Pluto eigentlich heute? Gibt es da so ein Video, so wie so Serienstars, was machen sie heute, so Pluto? Hey, erinnert ihr euch noch an Pluto, den neunten und außenstehendsten Planeten in unserem Sonnensystem und das macht er heute. Nach seiner unerfolgreichen Musikkarriere versucht er jetzt hier und da in Werbungen aufzutauchen.
Hier seht ihr aktuelle Bilder
von ihm. Wow, ich hätte ihn nicht wiedererkannt.
Hi, ich bin Pluto.
Hey, du warst doch früher der Planet.
Genau, ja, seitdem
war ich in Therapie
viel, um mit mir als
Zwergplanet klarzukommen.
Es ist halt schon so, dass man ich habe Millionen Jahre, das müssen Sie sich mal vorstellen, habe ich gedacht, ich bin einfach ein ganz normaler Planet. Alle haben mich auch so angesehen. War ich mal kleiner? Ja. Hat das was mit meinem Selbstbewusstsein gemacht? Sicherlich manchmal. Aber dass ich da jetzt einfach raus bin als Zwergplanet, ist man allen egal. Wir hatten sie ja eigentlich für unseren Kindergeburtstag gebucht, weil sie meinten, sie machen auch so Klauen. Ja, sorry, ich wollte auch nicht damit dem Thema anfangen. Nicht schon okay, wir haben ihnen alle gebannt zugehört, aber wir dachten uns, wenn sie vielleicht so ein paar Luftballonfiguren oder so machen könnten. Ich bin immer noch ein Planet. Okay, nein, wir respektieren das auch. Planet, aber Planet. Wir haben nur ihre Annonce in der Zeitung gelesen und dachten uns, das wäre vielleicht was. Hey, Leute, guck mal! Hey, das ist wieder ein Aal. Es ist wieder ein Aal. Gut, ich kann auch hier, Achtung, hier ist ein Hund. So ist ein Hund und so schirrt der Hund. Weil alle sagen ihm plötzlich, weißt du was, du bist kein Hund, du bist ein Luftballon-Hund. Alles klar. Du bist nur ein fucking Luftballon, du bist nicht mehr wert. Ich glaube, an der Stelle ... Geh weg, wir wollen dich nicht wieder sehen. Schön, dass sie da machen. Alle Sprichwerte, die ihr habt, machen keinen Sinn mehr. Alles klar, ich ruf jetzt die Polizei. Der Hund dachte die ganze Zeit, er wäre ein fucking Hund. Okay. Pluto war wirklich, tut mir sowieso leid. Pluto ist richtig abgestürzt. Nach dir vor, ist raus. Aber weiss man, der muss doch irgendwann in ein anderes Sonnensystem reingeraten, oder? Du bist ja nicht einfach ein Lonely Planet, oder? Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, Pond. Ja, genau. Frage. Nennt man, wenn man, es gibt Sterne, es gibt Planeten, es gibt Monde, Trabanten. Sind Monde, ist die Defin, du, es ist sehr schlau ich weiß, die sehr sehr schlaue Frage habe ich recht, ist die Frage am Ende, habe ich nicht recht weiss ich nicht mehr als hier, ist die Frage und die Monde die Definition von Monden ist, dass sie um Planeten kreisen, richtig? das war meine erste Frage, weißt du nicht, Kopfschütteln große, aufrissende ist deine Frage, dafür bist du jetzt ... Und nee, wie nennt man Dinge, die um Monde kreisen? Gibt es Dinge, die um Monde kreisen? Sicherlich. Mond, Mond. Nee, Mond, Mond. Oder kreisen die nie darum, weil die dann eher auf das stürzen? Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, du stellst Fragen nur, um mir meine Unwissenheit vor Augen zu führen.
Ich weiß, das ist ein pädagogisches Mittel von dir.
Du warst jetzt gar nicht gemeint.
Das funktioniert auch, sagst du ja immer bei deinen Freunden total gut, aber bei mir irgendwie, mich zieht es eher runter.
Okay, aber ich dachte, weil du manchmal reagierst ja auch lustig drauf mit einer spannenden Gegenfrage oder einer lustigen Antwort und so.
Und jetzt schiebst du es einfach komplett weg und sagst, pass auf, stellst du mich hier bloß?
Und das verstehe ich jetzt gar nicht, warum du jetzt nach so vielen Folgen dann nicht einfach checkst, dass es einfach auch lustig gemeint sein kann. Also ich finde es auch weh, das von den Leuten zu besprechen, aber ... Irgendwann müssen wir es ja besprechen. Ich meine, es hat ja 347 Folgen gedauert, bis wir überhaupt mal über unsere Gefühle sprechen. Dann können wir es jetzt auch mal offenlegen. Ja, okay. Ich fühl mich manchmal wie Pluto in unserer Beziehung. Du bist der Zwerg-Podcaster. Ich triff immer weiter weg. Du bist der Zwerg-Podcaster, ich bin Podcaster. Und ich habe noch kein anderes Sonnensystem gefunden. Ich schwirre ziellos durchs Universum. Aber das ist ja eigentlich das perfideste an der ganzen Pluto-Geschichte, an Pluto-Gate, ist ja, dass er immer noch hier abhängt. Er ist ja, das ist ja der Sinn von ihm, er wird sein Leben lang, sein Leben, das müsst ihr mir vorstellen, wird Pluto um die Sonne kreisen, die ihn nicht mehr als Planeten wahrhaben will. Da habe ich tatsächlich dann doch eine witzige Geschichte aus dem Alltag, ist mir doch vollkommen. Ach guck mal, jetzt geht es wieder. Ach, jetzt geht es dann plötzlich doch. Wenn wir einmal ehrlich werden, dann spudelt es dann doch wieder. Ah, okay, jetzt sind doch wieder kein Problem. Ja, alles klar, dann läuft der wieder. Zum Thema unnötig lange rumhängen, und zwar, ich bin ja oft, ich bin ja ein Freund des Carsharing und hole mir ab und zu diese Autos, die da rumstehen und fahre mit denen wild durch die Gegend, brause einfach, Witze, Flitze. Obwohl du gar kein Ziel zwangst. Neinne Ziel, ohne Licht. Du löst es eben ja aus. Und dann stand ich an der Ampel und neben mir fährt ein Auto ran und macht so diese, wie wir vielleicht zur Woche es hatten, diese veraltete Geste, das runter mit dem, runter mit der Scheibe. Ach, das Kirbeln. Genau, die hat er eben nicht mehr gemacht, die ist weg, sondern diese Finger nach unten, die kann man aber nicht zuordnen.
Ja, er zeigt dann in seinen Schritt einfach wild und du denkst, was? Und dann meinte er so, ja, zehn Euro, aber ja. Dann ziehe ich die Scheibe runter und er so, hey, wollen wir eine Viertelmeile machen? Wie bitte? Wollen wir eine Viertelmeile machen? Wollen wir eine Viertelmeile machen? und ich
verstehe nicht, was das bedeutet
ach so, weil ich dachte, weil wir dasselbe Auto hatten, dachte ich, es wäre witzig. Okay. Das war die Konversation. Das glaube ich jetzt nicht. Und ab dann, und es ist wirklich nicht gelogen, ab dann sind wir bei den nächsten drei Ampeln auch wieder nebeneinander gestanden.
Das ist das Unangenehmste. Ich wäre, glaube ich, recht abgebogen. Ohne Grund, ohne Sinn.
Ich habe es überhaupt nicht verstanden.
Wollen wir eine Viertelmeile machen?
Ich weiß nicht, also ich gehe davon rückblickend, ich habe das Ganze nochmal analysiert.
Ich glaube, es geht ja manchmal, wenn du zusammen an der roten Ampel stehst, dieses Schneller anfahren.
Genau, genau.
So, dieses Wettrennen. Und er meinte vielleicht, wir haben dasselbe Auto, weil er hatte auch ein Carsharing-Auto, das gleiche Modell. Du wurdest zum illegalen Strassenrennen in Hamburg aufgefordert. Richtig, genau. Aufgefordert. Mit den Worten, wollen wir eine Viertel? Das versteht. Und ich denke mir so, erstmal, eine Meile ist 1,6 Kilometer, ein Viertel davon sind jetzt 400. Ich kaffe überhaupt nichts. Sagen wir mal 400 Meter. Also allein diese verschiedene, diese imperiale Maßeinheitensystem. Null verstanden einfach. Null. Also eine Viertelmeile sind 402,336 Meter. So, okay. Ah, ein Beschleunigungsrennen. Ja, sagt man das so? Ein Beschleunigungsrennen, Drag-Race. Dragster-Rennen oder Drag Race, ja. Man muss einfach weiterlesen. Ist eine Motorsportveranstaltung. Nicht bei jedem einzelnen Buchstaben stehenbleiben. Nein, nein. Dra, hä, was soll denn Dra heißen? Ach so, Draak, ach so, Draak, Draak, ach so. Ja, ist eine Motorsportveranstaltung für Autos und Motorräder, bei der Motorräder, bei der eine gerade Strecke bei stehendem Start schnellstmöglich zurückzulegen ist, die traditionellsten Renndistanzen, die Viertelmeile, 400,2,3,4 m. Das kann man doch nicht voraussetzen, wenn du einen random Verkehrsteilnehmer machst. Aber das ist so lustig, weil das ist eine Szene, die in Filmen funktionieren würde, die in der Realität platzen, weil bei Filmen immer alle Charaktere den gleichen Wissenstand haben, aka den Kopf des Autoren, er hat die Kontrolle über alle Figuren und dementsprechend über die ganze Situation, deswegen bin ich Kontrollängste. Deswegen werden Gags auch verstanden. Man hat in Filmen relativ selten die Situation, sie ... Hä, wie meinst du das? Ich verstehe nichts. Bei mir hängt es an Meilen. Ich weiß nicht, warum fragen Sie das so? Dann erst mal drauf zu kommen, wir haben das gleiche Auto. Da frage ich mich auch, aber kann man so was nicht häufiger in Serien und Filmen einbauen, so dass auch Leute andere es einfach nicht hören? Sag ich was dazu gesagt? Und dann sage ich es einfach noch mal und dann geht die Szene noch mal weiter. Ich meine, man würde dann irgendwie so Chekhovs Gun-mässig denken, okay, die Figur wird taub, wird das noch mal relevant, aber nein, das ist einfach vielleicht ein Naturalismus, der vielleicht nicht funktioniert, aber so oft im Alltag, wie ich mir denke, dass man sagt, sorry, noch mal einmal bitte? Ach so, ja, passiert nicht in Serien, auch in der Bibel passiert das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was das, was ist das, was ist das, was ist das, was das, was ist das, was das, was ist das, was das, was ist das, was das, was das, was ist das, was das, was ist das, das ist das, was das, was das, was das, was das, was das ist ja. Und Wild RP heißt das, glaube ich. Und da wird Chekhov, ein Stück von Chekhov gespielt, in dem örtlichen Theater, in Red Dead Redemption. Und da muss man dann täglich zur Probe kommen. Und das hat für mich so viel ausgelöst, weil ich dachte, Alter, Wahnsinn, Wahnsinn, wie weit die Menschheit ist. Wir inzwischen spielen wir nach, aber dadurch verlierst er diesen Nachspielcharakter, weil er trotzdem proben muss. Also Leute spielen ein Spiel, Roleplayen darin, Schauspieler zu sein, als Schauspieler, die regelmäßig proben müssen, um ein Stück aufzuführen. Das hat ja so viele Meta-Layer, wo ich selber kurz irgendwie dachte, okay, wo stehen wir gerade, ist das alles eine Simulation, was bin ich, werde ich gespielt. Du hast im Twitch-Chat eine Diskussion begonnen, was das über uns aussieht. Ja, über Am I Alive, This Existence. Liege ich in einem Koma. Ja, liege ich in einem Koma, werde ich gerade gespielt von einer AI, what is happening, bin ich in NPC, diese ganze Frage, die man sich stellt. Und das war so ein komisches Erlebnis, das mitzubekommen. Und auch einfach eine Frage, geht es rein pragmatisch nach Zeitverschwendung? Ist es nicht dusselig, in einem Spiel Chekhov zu spielen, als dann nicht einfach in der Realität? Aber es ist natürlich viel besser im Spiel. Ja, total. Also ich fand das fantastisch. Ist natürlich auch passend, in der Westernwelt ein Chekhov-Stück aufzuführen, weil jeder denkt, wann kommt Chekhovs Gun, wann würden die Schauspieler erschossen oder so. Ja, aber das ist sehr lustig, weil da funktioniert es ja auch wieder nicht. Also das ist zwar quasi ein Spiel, alle sind Actors, alle haben sich überlegt, was ist mein Backstory und so, alle reden miteinander, verstehen sie aber trotzdem nicht. Das ist ja anders als im Film, und das wird einem in meinem Fall auch so ganz klar, Menschen verstehen sich nicht. Hey, wollen wir ein Viertelmeilenrennen machen? Was? Ich hatte auch das Fenster noch nicht mal ganz runter, weil das ist ja echtes Ding, wenn du, also diese Szene ist ja so anfällig für Fehler, weil jemand lässt das Fenster runter, ab wann fängt man an zu sprechen? Was würdest du sagen, ab wie viel Prozent des heruntergefahrenen Fensters muss man wirklich... Wie bitte? Ich wollte nur mal kurz sagen, dass sie das Licht anmachen sollten. Achso, Entschuldigung, Sie haben schon angefangen zu reden bei 20 Prozent. Ja, ich sag nur, weil das ist auch nicht so trivial. Wie bitte? Was sagen Sie? Das ist nicht so trivial, wenn man hier einfach in Hamburg ohne Licht rumfährt. Jetzt habe ich wieder nur die Hälfte verstanden. Aber es ist unangenehm langsam, vor allem, also sorry, ich meine, wir sind im Jahr 2023, Reminder, müssen diese Fenster so langsam sein? Wie wäre es mit einem Auto, neues Feature, einfach WOMM! Einfach schlagartig runter, tschöken ihr licht es nicht an, supp und wieder hoch und weiter. Ja, wirklich gut, schneller, pragmatischer, wir müssen ans Ziel kommen, müssen arbeiten, wir wollen mehr Freizeit, dann müssen schnell zu arbeiten, schnell nach Hause. Jeden Tag könnte man vier Minuten sparen. Ich kann verstehen, dass wenn es schnell zugeht, dannt man den Kopf oder so. Aber es runtergehen kann doch wirklich ... Einfach ... BAM! Runter! Manche Dinge sind so, weil sie immer schon so waren. Ja, weiter, weiter. Manche Dinge könnte man einfach improve. Wenn man darüber nachdenken würde, wie du jetzt gerade ... Hot-Tag, Hot-Tag. Mein Hot-Tag ist, Fenster könnten so schnell runter sein. Ja, oder auch die Autotüren an sich, die klingen alle gleich. Ist das mal aufgefallen? Alle Autotüren sind distinctive. Oh, das war so ein geiles Geräusch. Gutes Geräusch. Brauch es aber nicht. Brauch es nicht. Aber ein Kumpel von mir hat mal bei Mercedes-Benz gearbeitet. Mercedes-Benz Trademark. Und zwar war er dafür zuständig, wie der Sound klingt. Im Auto des Motors. Ein Problem, über das man sich... Moment mal, der Motor hat noch mal sein eigenes Auto. Nee, im Auto selbst. Ach so. Wie klingt der Motor im Auto selbst? Weil die bauen dann einen Motor. Aber wie kommt der Motor ins Auto? Braucht er nicht ein Auto, um in das Auto zu kommen? Wir sind nicht bei Cars oder so was. Okay, sorry, ich war grad ... Wo Menschen Autos sind und dann werden Autos gebaut. Ich dachte grad, was macht der Autos ... Okay, sorry, tschüss. Ich war grad völlig abgedenkt. Ja, genau, deswegen kommt zurück, kommt ins Jetzt, sei ihm Jetzt, Power of Now. Weil, wer bringt den Motor in das Auto, mit dem der Motor ins Auto fährt? Also wie kommen die Menschen zur Arbeit, wenn deren Autos keine Motoren haben? Wie kommt man zur Firma, wo die Autos hergestellt werden, wenn du noch kein Auto hast? Weil wenn du anfängst, bei Mercedes-Benz zu arbeiten, wie kommst du dann überhaupt zum... Wie kamen die ersten Menschen, die das erste Auto gebaut haben, überhaupt dahin? Hatte die erste Autofabrik Parkplätze? Wie? Weil ich meine, an dem... Du bist halt Ford. Dann glauben sie selber nicht dran. Wenn du sagst, Henry Ford baut seine Fabrik und sagt, wie viele Parkplätze brauchen wir? Es gibt null, es gibt exakt null Autos in der Welt gerade. Alle Strassen sind zu eng. Ja, aber du sagst, nee. Diese große, diese große, Henry, Henry, Henry, Henry, Henry, Henry. Ich hör zu. Ah, okay. Ich wollte nur fragen, warum diese große Freifläche vor unserer Fabrik, verstehe ich jetzt nicht. Also, sind irgendwie auch schöne Zeichnungen drauf, ist mit Kreide eingemalt irgendwie. Was stellen wir hierher? Das Automobil, Sir. Das Automobil, genau. Und diese hunderttausend Automobile, die in den nächsten Jahren hier vom Fließband laufen, meine Erfindung übrigens, wo sollen die stehen? Ich sage sie immer. Wo sollen die stehen? Alle wissen, dass es ihre Erfindung ist. Wo sollen die alle stehen? Das macht sie auch unsympathisch. Weiterdenken, weiterdenken. Naja, keine Ahnung, ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen, das ist eine Utopie, die ich mir gerade vorstelle. Die stehen alle vor unserem Haus. Vor unserem Haus? Die holen ihr Auto, fahren damit 50 Meter auf den Parkplatz, weil wir haben den einzigen Parkplatz der Welt. Aber das heißt, die kaufen bei uns das Automobil und fahren es nicht nach Hause, sondern auf unseren Parkplatz. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein Auto ab, fahren zum See, haben einen schönen Tag, fahren zurück zum Parkplatz, stellen ihr Auto ab und fahren mit der U-Bahn zurück nach Hause. Das heißt, bei uns stehen dann immer auf den Parkplätzen die Autos. Von allen Leuten, immer. Für alle Autos, die wir jemals verkaufen werden. Ja. Ich finde die Idee nicht cool. Jetzt, wo Sie, wenn Sie es so aussprechen. Ich würde den Space nutzen, um selber coolere Büros für uns und so. Oder halt mehr Fabrik. Ja, machen wir Bleistifte, oder? Komm, fuck it, wir bauen noch mal alles um Ford. Die Leute die Leute brauchen Bleistifte. Aber stimmt, du bist der Erste, der ein Auto kauft, und dann stellst du das einfach bei dir zu Hause auf die Straße oder was? Und dann geht der Scheibenbüscher nicht mehr. Was machst du dann? Was machst du dann? Oh, da bist du, hast dich in der Sackgasse manövriert. Mal wieder. Die, von denen es viele gibt. Ja, und vor allem, mit wem fährst du eine Viertelmeile, wenn du das einzige Auto bist? Es ist so ein merkwürdiger Aufruf zu einem Duell.
Aber ich habe ja an sich Bock auf Duelle, verstehe mich nicht falsch.
Ich habe ja Bock auf Duelle, ab jetzt werde ich ja jedes Viertelmeilenrennen gerne annehmen, kein Problem.
Aber ich habe es in dem Moment einfach nicht verstanden.
Genau wie so Cowboys oder so.
Stell dir mal vor, dass jemand zum Duell heraus, weiss aber einfach nicht, wie es läuft.
Und dann kommt der Saloon, lehrt sich und die Dorfbewohner kommen raus, dann steht man gegenüber dem anderen Cowboy und so. Und dann hat irgendwer dann ... Worauf warten die eigentlich immer? Ja, da gibt's so einen Schiedsrichter oder so was. Manchmal gab's einen Schiedsrichter, was ... Zehn Schritte oder so was in der Richtung. Du musst erst mal die Regeln kennen. Ich weiss es doch auch nicht und so, aber ... Es ... Ich habe auch immer nicht verstanden, genau, ja gut, das ist das alte Duell, ne, irgendwie Rücken an Rücken sein, dann zehn Schritte gehen und dann umdrehen und dann ... Aber ich verstehe nicht, warum nicht alle cheaten dabei, weil ... Ich kann's, ich verstehe es wirklich auch nicht. Aber das ist auch interessant. Wieso, weil du dann unährenhaft gehst. Ja, das ist so interessant, dass dieses Konzept der Ehre so komplett weg ist. Also wenn man heute alle, alle streiten sich im Internet irgendwie, alle super aufgebraust, aber damals haben die Leute sich halt einfach umgebracht. Wenn du irgendwie mit jemandem, wenn dich jemand blöd beleidigt hat auf Twitter, sagst, okay, morgen, großer Platz, wir schießen uns einfach gegenseitig. Und dann hat man da, und dann hat man gesagt, nee, morgen kann ich nicht, da habe ich einen Zahnarzttermin, lass uns mal mal übermorgen sagen. Und dann hast du zwei Tage deines Lebens gelebt mit dem Wissen, dass du in zwei Tagen vielleicht zu 50 Prozent einfach tot bist. Und du sagst, oh, ich habe heute ich habe heute um 16 Uhr habe ich ein Duell. Nee, okay, dann lass uns um 14 Uhr noch den Termin machen. Um zwölf, ich um 12 noch meine Schuhe machen und ... Vater, Vater, geh doch einfach nicht zu diesem Duell. Wie, bis 16 Uhr, ich habe Zeit. Meine Schwester und ich, wir brauchen dich, wir wollen nicht ohne Vater aufwachsen. Der Typ hat auf Twitter zu mir gesagt, dass meine Ansichten radikal sind und ich mit der Radikalität dem Zweck eigentlich eher schade, als dass ich helfe. Ja, aber jetzt sieht er niemand mehr. Maischberger hat den Ursprungs-Tweet ja zurückgenommen. Man sieht es ja jetzt nicht. Nein, man sieht trotzdem noch den Reply. Oder? Aber ich ... Man sieht trotzdem noch den Reply. Dafür verlange ich Satisfaktion. Meine Schwester und ich sollten nicht ohne Vater aufwachsen, nur weil du unter Maischberger-Tweets in meine grossen politischen Diskussionen anfasst. Wollt ihr lieber einen Vater haben, der sich auf Twitter beleidigen lässt, als gar kein Vater? Ist das, was du sagst? Wirklich? Ja, das ist, was ich sagen will, ja. Wirklich? Ja. Willst du mich jetzt auch umbringen? Verrückt. Wollen wir uns jetzt auch? Okay, ich fordere dich, mein Sohn, zum Duell. Mama, Mama, Mama, Mama. Ja, nein, Mama. Hey, du musst annehmen, ansonsten hast du keine Ehre. Ja, hab ich wohl keine Ehre. Sorry, Paps. Hä? Das geht nicht. Hä, das ist eine Option, hä? Die Welt verändert sich so schnell gerade. Wobei, ich habe schon das Gefühl, dass gerade sehr viele um ihre Ehre kämpfen. Das ist doch eigentlich, worum es geht gerade. Hot Take, kleiner Hot Take, will ich gar nicht tiefer drauf eingehen, was ich da meine. Denn manchmal sind kleine Dinge, werden einfach so Mystery Box in die Welt geschickt. Hat sich das verändert, als die Leute keine Waffen mehr hatten? Dass man dann keine Duelle mehr gemacht hat? Und ich glaube, die hatten nicht mal ihre eigenen Waffen. Es gibt kaum Waffen mehr, ne? In Deutschland nicht. Ja, hier ist es nicht. Aber in den USA werden auch nicht die ganze Zeit Duelle durchgefechtet, gefochten. Gab's Duelle? Ich weiß es nicht. Interessant, die Geschichte des Duells würde dich noch interessieren, falls ihr da eine Doktorarbeit hat oder ein Booklet. Apropos Duelle. Oder welche Welle oder sowas. Ich hab ähm ... Super Bowl! Nee. Hast du einen Super Bowl gesehen? Alter! Wie der den Ball geworfen hat und der andere rennt, rennt, rennt. Renn, rennt und fängt ihn. Aber dann fällt der um und fällt mir den Ball doch. Das war so geil. Und wie der sich ins Publikum gesetzt hat. Und dann schießt er sich da, gefiffen und gesagt, hat er was gesagt. Und dann in der Pause, Rihanna hat gesungen und dann hat, dann wurde es scheinbar dunkel. Und dann wurde ich richtig müde. In Echtzeit wurde der Himmel dunkler über dem Schein. Ja, das war richtig geil. Ich wurde so müde. Ich wurde so müde. Dann habe ich geschlafen, die ganze Nacht geschlafen? U, S, ich wollte USA sagen und bei S bin ich eingeschlafen.
U, S, wenn ich eingeschlafen.
Und dann die ganze Nacht geschlafen, geschlafen und dann morgens ist er weg.
Und ich bin aufgestanden und gedacht, what the fuck, es war so geil.
Und ich bin aufgewacht und ich hatte noch so viele Snacks, ich hatte noch so viele Chicken Wings übrig und dann habe ich als Frühstück zwei Tüten Chips und vierzig Chicken Wings gegessen und dann war mir den ganzen Tag schlecht.
War so geil.
Es war so geil, es war best night ever.
Nee, ich wollte eigentlich über die Olympischen Spiele sprechen, Entschuldigung. Entschuldigung. Die was? Die Olympischen Spiele. Weil, die sind nicht, aber die kommen bald. Ich habe noch nie davon gehört. Ja, es ist ein interkontinentaler Wettbewerb zwischen den Nationen der Welt, die in allen Sportarten gegeneinander antreten und herausfinden wollen, wer ist das beste Land der Welt. Das habe ich noch nie gehört. Was ist das beste, coolste Land der Welt? Ja. So, und da gibt es jetzt dreimal drei gegen drei Basketball. Mega weird. Einfach eine andere Sportart. Wie viel war es davor? Fünf gegen fünf? Nee, es gibt auch noch das normale Basketball. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele es sind. Wie groß die Mannschaft? Sechs gegen sechs, fünf gegen fünf? Moment, aber das heißt das deutsche Basketball-Nationalmannschaftsteam. Es sind sechs Leute, die sagen, es gibt jetzt drei v drei. Es gibt welche, die freiwillig nicht dabei sein wollen. Niemand? Niemand meldet sich? Niemand meldet sich, also alle wollen dabei sein. Also müssen wir jetzt bewerten, wer die besten Spieler sind. Müssen wir jetzt, okay. Oder wir machen zwei Mannschaften. Weil wenn hier sechs Spieler sind und drei v drei, können wir nicht nochmal Ost-West nochmal, können wir nicht nochmal sagen, wir machen Ost-Deutschland-Westdeutschland, dann haben wir zwei Mannschaften und wenn ihr aber gegeneinander gepaart werdet, dann verliert beide absichtlich, okay? Wie, wenn man gegeneinander gepaart wird, verliert beide absichtlich? Ja, weil wir eigentlich sind ja ein Team verdeckt, dann verlieren beide absichtlich, sodass beide verlieren. Aber dann ist es unentschieden oder was? Nein, es können auch beide verlieren. Es können beide Mannschaften verlieren? Wer null Punkte hat am Ende, hat automatisch verloren. Dann verlieren wir beide, okay? Okay, super, so machen wir es. Okay, Deal. Ich finde, du solltest raus sein, weil du das Schlechteste von uns bist. Ich bin der Trainer. Ja, das sagt so viel und so Mannschaft aus.
Aber drei mal drei?
Drei gegen drei.
Nicht drei Mannschaften.
Nicht drei mal drei.
Drei gegen drei. Ich fände drei mal drei V3 V3, fände ich spannend.
Ah ja, so ein Dreiextrem.
Aber du hast nur zwei Körbe, aber trotzdem drei Mannschaften.
Und die eine Mannschaft muss immer auf den Korb werfen, wo sie den Ball nicht erobert hat in der Spielfeldhälfte. Ja, das fände ich spannend. Finde ich auch super. Generell habe ich da gedacht, aber Leute, ihr sägt an eurem eigenen Ast, weil jetzt ist ja alles möglich. Jetzt hat es ja, weißt du, du stellst das Regenbuch in Frage, weil jetzt ist ja jetzt doch bitte dann auch irgendwie Schwimmen, aber ja, vor allem ist es ja merkwürdig, wenn irgendwie in Basketball 6v6 gewinnt das eine Land, Rumänien, und 3v3 gewinnt irgendwie Spanien. Und du denkst dir, hä? Also die Spanier sind besser in kleinen Gruppen und die Rumänen besser in großen Gruppenppen? Sind die sich eigentlich ab dem Punkt so ähnlich, dass man sagt, das ist doch jetzt Quatsch? Voll cool, weil beim Schach gibt es ja auch verschiedene Bedenkzeiten und es gibt auch manchmal sehr verschiedene Weltmeister in verschiedenen Bedenkzeiten. Aber darf der selbe Basketballer in dem Sechser-Team und dem Dreier-Team auch gleichzeitig mitmachen oder muss man sich entscheiden? Du stellst Fragen, auf die ich keine Antwort habe. Aber Vincent Keimer zum Beispiel, der Prodigy, der Sachprodigy, nach mir kam der direkt, hat mir ein bisschen den Rang abgelaufen. Der Zweitbeste der Geschichte. Hat mir den Rang abgelaufen. Er ist, glaube ich, jetzt vielleicht liege ich falsch, aber beim World Blitz Tournament, also für die Weltmeisterschaft im Blitz, ist er Zweiter geworden,
Vize-Weltmeister und hat jetzt, klar, ist auch ab und zu formabhängig,
aber in einem anderen Turnier, sei es klanglos irgendwie vorletzter geworden
bei einer klassischen Bedenkzeit.
Aber er ist einfach jung und frisch und wahnsinnig schnell im Kopf.
Und das fand ich so spannend, das macht sehr viel aus.
Und dann dachte ich mir, gut, andere Sportarten, mal einfach so das Umkrempeln, Regeländerungen einführen und sowas. Ja, das wär mein Traum, ist, ich würd gern an so einem Blitzschachturnier teilnehmen und wirklich da auftreten, wirklich mit Anzug, irgendwie ernst im Blick, wirklich noch mal so in sich gehen, und dann geht die Zeit los und ich mach nur NonsensZüge. Also wirklich, aber mit völligem Ernst, wirklich, ich bin voll in der Zone, einfach willkürliche Züge und einfach nur und dann irgendwie der Gegner schlägt mich in drei Züge und ich so na okay, Handshake, Handshake und dann noch kurz über die Partie reden. Nur noch kurz, aber man hört dich nicht, aber man sieht so, die Kamera ist auf dich drauf und du gehst so gut gut und sagst, und der andere so, nee, das macht gar keinen Sinn, der zugegeben. When you did this, I knew I was fucked. I mean, I couldn't go here and here, but I did this. Hallo Herr Will, Sie haben gerade nur Nonsens gespielt, was war da los irgendwie? Ja, um mal ganz ehrlich zu sein, ich weiß von den meisten Figuren gar nicht, wie die sich bewegen dürfen, weiss nur die kleinen, die heißen die kleinen in der ersten Reihe. Die Bauern. Die Bauern, genau. Ich dachte, ich presche mit denen nach vorne, so schnell es geht. Das war ja erst mal gar nicht so schlecht. Da sah es kurz so aus, würden Sie wirklich was vom Spiel verstehen. Genau, genau, ich habe einfach den einen Bauer immer weiter nach vorne gerückt. Ja, das war merkwürdig. Den einen Bauern immer noch weiter nach vorne. In kürzester Zeit habe ich verloren. Sie waren noch im Schach und haben trotzdem den König nicht bewegt. Korrekt, Rahmani hat das fantastisch gemacht. Er hat gut gespielt, er ist ein guter Spieler. Ich wusste, das wird ein hartes Spiel. Er ist einfach ein Spieler. Sie haben das noch nie gemacht. Es wird ein hartes Spiel. Ich bin reingegangen. Wie sind Sie in diesen Raum gekommen? Warum sind Sie denn so ein Badge? Da steht Spieler. Wie sind Sie die Worte reingekommen? Ich bin einfach extrem schnell. Wissen Sie, ich bin extrem schnell. Ich habe die schnellsten Züge. Und manchmal meine Kontrahenten, vor allem diese ganzen 14-jährigen Russen da, die haben sich leider teilweise verheddert und haben zu lange gebraucht und deswegen, ja die Vorbereitung war intensiv, es ist ein sehr, sehr guter Spieler, tut mir leid, sechs Zügen verloren, wir sehen uns nächstes Jahr wieder. Ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, wir sollten sie nicht mehr einladen. Aber es gibt ja immer so Schachpartien, wo dann so eine traube Mensch drumherum steht.
Und so würde ich gerne wirklich einfach voll im Ernst ... Naja, okay, ja. Nonsens, nur Nonsens. Mein lieber, lieber Freund Raphael, manche kennen ihn von Rocket Beans, Raffo, der spielt ja Schach im Verein, und er hat, das ist sehr gemein, dass ich diese Story erzähle, aber ich glaube, er hat mal irgendwann gesagt, das ist völlig okay. Er hat gegen am Wochenende, dann hat er immer sonntags oft Partien gegen andere Mannschaften und er wurde gegen einen Zehnjährigen zugeteilt. An Brett vier hat er gegen einen Zehnjährigen gespielt und verloren. Und ich hätte so viele Fragen dazu. Zum einen, weil Zehnjährige können sich ja nicht so lange konzentrieren.
Ich stelle mir vor, wie er dann von seinem Vater hingebracht wurde und dann wurde er so auf den Stuhl gesetzt. Der Stuhl war auch sehr gross, der Stuhl für diesen kleinen Mann. Mann. Dann sitzt er da in seinem Spider-Man-Shirt, die gegenüber Zug vier, die Dame ist bedroht,
oh da kommt die Mutter und bringt ihm einen Teller mit geschnittenen Äpfeln. Oh, anscheinend, er möchte die Äpfel nicht haben, er verlangt Kaba. Die Mutter behaart auf den Äpfelschnitzen. Oh, und da wird nochmal, da reibt sie ihm die Wange nochmal. Ja, da sitzt sie sich. Ziem peinlich, Mama stört beim Spielfluss, aber vielleicht, manche sagen auch, dass sie ihm hilft. Haben deine Eltern dir geholfen bei deinen Spielen? Nein, sie haben mich überhaupt nicht unterstützt. Ich musste selbst mir alles beibringen, was ich wollte. Ich bin Letztplatzierter bei allen grossen Turnieren geworden. Immerhin hat es dem Kommentator gereicht. Ja, manchmal sagt man, je schlechter der Spieler, desto besser der Kommentator. Nicht wahr? Wir konzentrieren uns zurück auf das Spiel. Oh, Schlafenszeit. Ich möchte mehr über dich reden, mehr über dich erfahren. Okay, also ich meine, wie gesagt, ich habe bei den US Grand Opens den letzten Platz belegt, in den Thai Opens habe ich den letzten Platz belegt, ich habe es mit Snooker probiert, da auch den letzten Platz belegt. Vielleicht ist das Sport einfach nicht für dich. Lass es zurück, einfach so Partie kommen. Meine Eltern nehme ich überhaupt gar nicht ernst. Ich bin nur Kommentator und habe nie was daran erreicht. Alles klar. Oh, jetzt kommt die Mutter mit dem Schlafanzug, ist es Schlafenszeit? Ja. Da gibt es eine kleine Debatte. Und ich finde das so lustig. Da hat er wirklich verloren. Und da gab es dann auch irgendwann, weil ihm, also die ganze Mannschaft hat die halt, also Raffos Mannschaft hat die andere Mannschaft komplett besiegt in allen Partien. Irgendwann war da nur noch diese Partie am Laufen. Und Raffo hat es, sag mal, gar nicht ernst genommen. Ich verstehe das komplett. Gegen den Zehnjährigen nimmst du es ja auch nicht ernst. Das ist der Fehler. Man denkt so, ich mache eh alles scheißegal. Und irgendwann waren dann halt alle Spiele schon gelaufen. Und der unangenehmste Moment ist dann, wenn dann die Traube aus. Und dann war halt hinten diese Horde Zehnjährige und hinter ihm einfach die erwachsenen Männer. Von Herren zwei, weiß ich nicht, und haben die gegeneinander gespielt und dann hat Raff und Zug gemacht und die ganzen Kinder im Hintergrund haben schon gejubelt, weil sie dachten, also haben sie auch ungebührlich verhalten, weil es Zehnjährige sind, die gleich fucking Spongebob gucken, dann ist Haya. Sie haben alle gedabbt. Haben alle, sind alle ausgeflippt. What the fuck is happening? Der eine wollte die Mutter fragen, ob er nicht eine Switch schon bekommen kann, weil er hält das nicht aus, weil so lange kann man sich nicht konzentrieren. Und dann haben die sich über gefreut, weil er Rafa einen doofen Zug gemacht hat, dachte er dann auch und hat dann aufgegeben und seine Mannschaft war so entsetzt, weil sie dachten, nee, du hast nicht verloren. Also die haben alle, weil das alle Kinder sind, nur nicht gecheckt, dass es ein guter Zug war, haben dann so gejubelt.
Er hat aufgegeben und hat ihm seinen Kumpel, Teamkamerad, dann so wieder aufgebaut das Feld und gesagt, nee, jetzt einfach das machen müssen wir jetzt ja gewonnen. Und da hatte ich mal diese Bande aus Zehnjährigen, diesen Fohlensohr, diese Rasselbande, die kleinen, die wilden Kerle des Schachs, haben den dann so mit Malern und den Anführern und so, haben ihm ein Schnippchen geschlagen. Unglaublich. Aber ich kann das total gut verstehen. So Sachen wie Tilt und Enttäuschung und der emotionale Faktor ist so wichtig bei solchen Sachen. Als Zuschauer unterschätzt man das immer, aber ich kenne das so gut, wenn man selber Videospiele spielt und so und dann tiltet wegen dummen kleinen Fehlern und sich hasst, weil man denkt, ich kann es besser. Es ist hart, es ist schwierig. Es ist superhart. Das fand ich super interessant. Auch weil der ein ganz anderes Tagesablauf hat, dieser Junge. Der wird dann morgens hingebracht, weiß auch noch nicht genau, was passiert in der Welt, wird dann an so ein Brettetzt, muss ein paar Züge machen, gewinnt zum ersten Mal in seinem Leben. Der darf nicht so lange aufbleiben, wie er will. Und Raffo hat, nein, Raffo darf so lange aufbleiben, wie er will. Oder darf er mittlerweile? Danach halt nicht mehr, danach haben die Erinnerungen gesagt, so, jetzt müssen wir wieder, du auch Zehnjähriger, jetzt musst du deine Erwachsenheit wieder verdienen. Also, fand ich so Wahnsinn. Ja. Und weil der, es ist natürlich, wir prallen einfach zwei Welten aufeinander, und da habe ich auch überlegt, ich will eigentlich auch einen Schachverein, um gegen Zehnjährige zu verlieren. Ja, total. Das ist total lustig. Ich will auch einem Zehnjährigen einfach zugucken, wie er fünf Stunden mir gegenüber sitzt und struggelt damit, die Aufmerksamkeit zu behalten. Wie weird ist das? Ich finde das fantastisch.
Es ist schon verliebt.
Und hat Raffo alle Elo-Punkte, die er in den letzten vier Jahren gesammelt hat, alle wieder verloren.
Er hat jetzt weniger, als er angefangen hat, weil er gegen den Zehnjährigen verloren hat, der irgendwie Elo von 600 hatte.
Schrecklich. Also wirklich alles daran.
Und man kann sich ja auch selber nicht mehr ernst nehmen, wenn man in so einem Denksport gegen den Zehnjährigen verliert, der das kaum kann. Also, ich würde mich an seiner Stelle nicht mehr ernst. Raffo, falls du zuhörst. Aber in diesem Sinne alles Gute. Aber Raffo ist eh strange, also können wir eh nochmal. Äh, nee, eigentlich superguter Kurkern. Ja, ja, nee, aber können wir. Strange sagst, in aller Öffentlichkeit auch. Also, in aller Öffentlichkeit ist es auch übertrieben. Ja, nee, aber das ist ein gutes anderes Thema. Nee, aber es ist jetzt nicht ... So, aber dann, wie war deine Reaktion? Also das Fenster schnellte zu. Schnellte zu, gar nicht, ich habe es erst nicht verstanden. Und dann, das ist auch, ich glaube, das ist der dümmste Satz, den man so rufen kann, so dieses Ich weiß nicht, was Sie damit meinen! Und man will ja auch cool sein. Zuerst, wenn man die akustischen Probleme aus dem Weg geschafft hat, so, und dann so Aber eine Viertelmeide fahren! Ich weiß nicht, was Sie damit meinen! Können Sie das spezifizieren? Ich kann mit dieser, in dieser konkreten Reihe an Worten, kann ich nichts anfangen.
Welches Wort verstehen Sie nicht? Ich verstehe jedes einzelne Wort, nur der Zusammenhang ergibt sich mir noch nicht. Okay, ob wir nicht ein Viertelmeilenrennen anfangen, oh, es ist grün, ciao. Oh Gott, ey. Furchtbar, wirklich ganz schrecklich. Aber wirklich, es ist wirklich genau richtig, weil ich habe, ich bin, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht bin ich ein schlechter Autofahrer, keine Ahnung. Aber ich fahr auch so nachts nach einer Rocket Beans TV Sendung, fahr ich durch die Gegend und dann wird hinter mir halt hinter mir halt hartgelichthubt. Und dann denke ich, ja okay, keine Ahnung, vielleicht fahr ich irgendwie, mancher wird mir nicht schon angehubt, wenn man irgendwie fünf Kilometer zu langsam fährt, 45 in der Stadt, wird man schon angelichthubt, irgendwie Party-Truppe oder so hinter einem, die wollen zum Club, die wollen feiern, der Feierabend des Lebens kurz, dieserichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte, die Lichte dachte, fuck, irgendwas stimmt hier nicht. Fahr rechts ran, Auto fährt links neben mir ran. Und ich lasse erst die Fensterscheide. Wollen wir mit einem Siebenachtel-Meilen-Renn fahren? Wollen wir mit einem Drei-Unzen-Rennen machen? Sorry, ich weiß nicht. Was sind Drei-Unzen mit mal vier Pfund? Und dann die Autofahrerin meinte so, man merkt, dass sie nicht oft Autofahren, hier licht es aus. Aber das ist schon wieder passiert, Florianzin. Weil das ist schon mal passiert. Es war mitten in der Innenstadt mit Laternen und so, ich hätte das Licht gar nicht gebraucht. Weil das Problem bei diesen Car-to-go-Autos ist, die haben Standlicht. Bei manchen ist es automatisch an. Auch ein Problem, okay, aber die haben Standlicht. Das heißt, du machst dein Auto an und du hast ein Licht sofort, was kommt. Das ist kein, es ist nicht hell genug, es ist nur ein sogenanntes Standlicht. Ja, das hast du mir schon mal erklärt. Und dann denkst du nämlich, das Licht wäre an und du fährst los. Ich dachte, es ist bei modernen Autos gar nicht mehr möglich, ohne Licht zu fahren, aber da anscheinend, und vor allem, es wurde noch demütigender, weil diese Autofahrerin fuhr neben mich. Wieso fängt sich erst mal an mit dem Satz, man merkt, dass sie nicht auf Autofahren, ja wow, man merkt, dass sie nicht auf Feedback geben, weil das ist eine Arschloch-Antwort. Aber vielleicht, ich kann es dir vielleicht erklären, weil vielleicht hat sich dieser Eindruck dann doch verfestigt, sie fuhr nämlich links neben mich ran und sie hat ihre Scheibe runtergefahren. War sie Beifahrerin oder Fahrerin? Sie war Fahrerin. Wow, das heißt, sie hat über den Beifahrersitz hinweg? Ja, natürlich. Und ich wollte auch meine Scheibe runterfahren, da das Auto mir aber unbekannt war. Da mir das Auto aber unbekannt war, habe ich aus Versehen die Scheibe vom Rücksitz runtergefahren. Ab diesem Moment dachte sie, in dem Auto sitzt einfach ein Hund. Ja, also das ist die der schlechteste Mündigkeit. Nur der Malker fährt ohne Licht Schlangenlinien der falschen Strassenseite durch Hamburg. Und dann wird mant und dann so. In dem Moment hat sie gehofft, du bist betrunken. Sie hat gehofft, du bist betrunken. Für dessen sitzt da einfach ein Typ nüchtern, er sieht jetzt super brav, Jacke an, braver Lesebrille auf, super konzentriert, beide Hände am Lenkrad und versuchst dein Bestes, gibst dein absolut Bestes und es tut dir einfach leid.
Aber es gibt nichts demütigendes als, du suchst den Knopf, findest den Knopf, schaust sie schon so an, so ja, nickend, drückst du auf und hinten geht das Fenster runter. Ich denke, es ist so demütigend. So demütigend. Weil auf der anderen Seite denkt sie, er hat das Fenster noch nicht runter gemacht.
Aber auf der gleichen Seite sieht sie den Fehler auch noch so klar. Sie sieht sofort erstellen, wovon du willst mit ihr reden und hinten geht das Fenster runter. Und dann dachte ich auch so reden wir jetzt über das hintere Fenster? Ach Gott, richtig unangenehm. Aber hat sie gelacht darüber? Null. Überhaupt nicht. Einfach nur so einem selbstsicheren, aber man merkt, dass sie nicht häufig Autofahren. Na gut, wenn sie dann gefahren wäre, wäre sie so, ah, fuck it, fuck this guy, das wird nicht besser. Ich kann ihm jetzt drei Dinge sagen, die er falsch macht oder komm, lass ne, lass ne. Ich glaube, ich bin wirklich noch 20 Sekunden stehen geblieben, um einfach dieses Scham aufzusaugen, um einfach dieses
das hat gerade so
so gar nicht funktioniert.
Und willst du das Warnblinklicht anmachen, damit
die Autos nicht, damit die Hindernisse erkennen,
machst du den Scheibenwischer.
Ach, du so
Scheiße.
Ich glaube, diese Themen, die du erzählst,
sind super für so einen Film, wo man am Anfang eine Figur... Ja, Baby Driver. Baby am Steuer. Ne, genau, a literal fucking Baby am Steuer. Das ist wie Boss Baby, nur Baby Driver. Ja. Ne, sind so für Filme, wo am Anfang, man will Leute bei Rock Bottom zeigen. Ja, genau. Man will Leute... Save the Cat, sympathisch, weil Loser. Weil Fucking Loser. Ja. Also wenn du mir da mehr Geschichten aus deinem Leben erzählen könntest. Fucking kann jedem passieren, würde ich jetzt sagen, eher. Kann jedem mal passieren. Ja. Wahnsinn, völlig, völlig fantastisch. Gefällt mir sehr gut. Aber ich meine, sie ist halt auch hardcore reingegangen, also man merkt, dass sie nicht oft Auto fahren. Holy Ja, okay. Aber ja, an welchem Punkt ist es gerechtfertigt? Du merkst ja selber auch nicht, was du für ein Trottel bist, wenn du so dich dagegen fährst. Das ist das Klassische, du hast irgendwie einen Zettel am Rücken hängen oder so. Ach ja, Wahnsinn. Ich finde, wenn ihr Leute bemerkt, die Fehler machen und ihr könnt denen helfen, geht nicht mit dieser Attitude rein, geht nicht rein mit, man merkt, dass sie das nicht oft machen oder so. Seid nett, helft, man will nicht so angequatscht werden. Ja, vielleicht war es so ein bisschen witzig, so ja, haha, aber schwierig, Feedback ist eine schwierige Sache. Wann genau gibt man Feedback, wann nicht? Wann hilft man nach? Also eine Sache, wo...
Eine Freundin von mir hat jetzt einen Hund, die kriegt so viel Feedback mit diesem Hund umgehen. Und das ist das Schlimmste. Den müssen sie an die kürzere Leine nehmen. Nee, das ist ganz schrecklich. Und dann war ich mit ihr und dem Hund unterwegs in so einem Hundepark und dann kam so ein Riesenhund an, so ein grosser schwarzer Grimm.
Sie riss Black. Kam an und hat den Hund, den kleinen Welpen, so attackiert mässig. Der kleine Welpe, habe mich geert geführt, kam dann zu mir, hat bei mir Schutz gesucht. Und ich sass auf der Wiese, das war schon ein paar Monate her, und er springt in meinen Schoss, um Schutz zu suchen. Und ich dachte mir, das tut mir so. Und dann kam der andere immer weiter und das Herrchen hat den nicht weggezogen. Dann habe ich den kleinen Hund umarmt und bin dann aufgestanden mit dem, damit der Hund den nicht angreifen kann, woraufhin der Besitzer zu mir kam und gesagt hat, machen Sie das nie. Sie können dem, Sie dürfen dem Hund keinen Schutz geben. Dann weist er, dass er immer zu Ihnen kommen kann, um Schutz zu suchen, aber er muss lernen. Ich habe das nicht genau, das klingt so weird, auch rückblickend immer noch. Was ist für ein Tipp, er weist, dass er bei mir immer Schutz bekommt. Ja, wenn ich da bin, werde ich ihm auch Schutz bieten, wenn dieser andere Hund ankommt. Dann hat er mir so einen zehn Minuten Vortrag gehalten, warum das jetzt erziehungstechnisch eine total duttelige Idee war, weil er immer ankommt und bettelt, wenn ihm was widerfährt und so was. Ja, ja, er muss hart werden. Er muss hart, genau. Nur die Harten kommen in den Garten, mässig. Solche Sätze fielen, glaube ich, auch in Cooler. Aber ich fand das so, ich schon, und ich war ja unbeteiligte dritte Person und war einmal mit dem Hund unterwegs und habe dann direkt so ein Referat bekommen, wie man den erziehen sollte. Ich würde durchdringen, glaube ich, als Hundebesitzer hin, würde ich ausflippen. Du wirst die ganze Zeit belehrt und so, wenn ich Ihnen kurz Feedback geben könnte, ist jemand scheinbar nicht so lange ein Hund. Judge me. Steht das auf meiner Stirn? Ja. Ich will das nicht. Vor allem, wenn du niemand anderen anderen damit belästigst. Ich kann ja verstehen, wenn du jemandem im Weg stehst. Aber wenn das wirklich dein Hund ist und so, hat man nicht ein Recht, seinen Hund zu verkorksen. Dann hast du halt einen weichen Hund. So, mein Gott. Also ich meine, das ist ja gutes Recht. Oder gibt es die moralische Pflicht, dass man seinen Hund irgendwie super tough erziehen muss? Es gibt ein Foto von einem Introvert-Dog-Club, wo sehr viele Leute zusammenkommen, die, wie sie denken, introvertete Hunde haben und die dann zusammenbringen. Und Hunde spielen dann immer zusammen, aber das ist einfach eine Wiese mit meist Männern und ihren kleinen Hunden, die einfach unbeteiligt da stehen und so aussehen, als hätten sie für das Foto pausiert, weil alle haben diesen gleichen Abstand, interagieren nicht, die Hunde schauen sich nicht in die Augen, die Hunde wollen einfach nur nach Hause. Ja, einfach awkward silence, jeder hat so seinen Drink in der Hand, man schaut sich nicht an, so. Und alle sitzen so die Zeit ab, bis es dann wieder okay ist, nach Hause zu gehen. Das ist fantastisch. Ich finde das so toll, ich finde das so süß. Introvertierte Tiere ist, glaube ich, nichts Besseres. Ja. Nee, aber wo ich mittlerweile Feedback gebe, und ich weiß nicht, ich habe wirklich das Gefühl, ich spüre so in mir dieses Rentnergehen aufbl aufblühen und manchmal denke ich mir, es ist
ja, es ist, ich habe das Gefühl,
das ist wie so eine Superkraft, weil irgendwie
kommen mir Rentner manchmal so wie Superhelden vor,
denen ist alles scheißegal,
die Schnauzen an, das ist das Selbstbewusstsein
und es ist eine Art Superkraft, so und dieses
mir ist alles egal, ich setze meinen Willen durch
und auch wenn ich, ist mir egal, ob ich Arschloch bin
und manchmal denke ich mir so, ich habe diese
Kraft noch nicht ganz in mir, aber mein
aktueller Riesen-Pet-Pief ist
Schlangen bei Bäcker, Schlangen
Vielen Dank. Und auch wenn ich, ist mir egal, ob ich Arschloch bin, und manchmal denke ich mir so, ich habe diese Kraft noch nicht ganz in mir, aber mein aktueller Riesen-Pet-Pief ist Schlangen bei Bäcker, Schlangen bei Bäckereien, und zwar bei Bäckereien in Supermärkten. Und ich weiß nicht, wer sich dieses Design ausgedacht hat, in der Regel ist es so, die Tür geht auf des Supermarkts, man geht gerade durch in den Supermarkt hinein und rechts oder links ist die Bäckerei, so dass wenn du dich jetzt im 90-Grad-Winkel zur Bäckerei ziegst. Die meisten Dinge sind links oder rechts.
Ja, gut, aber du musst sozusagen an der Bäckerei oder oben oder unten.
Aber das heißt, wenn du in den Supermarkt willst, musst du an der Bäckerei vorbei in der Regel.
Und das heißt, oft ist das Layout so, dass wenn du dich im 90-Grad-Winkel zur Bäckerei anstellst,
du blockierst
den Weg in den Supermarkt.
Und da denke ich mir wirklich, das kann
doch nicht wahr sein, dass die Leute
nicht checken, es gibt einen ganz schlimmen
Supermarkt in München, wo diese
Bäckereischlange wirklich direkt
vor diesem Saloon-Tür
in den Supermarktbereich ist.
Das heißt, die Leute stehen wirklich mit der linken
Hüfte direkt an dieser Tür,
wo man in den Supermarktbereich kommt
Und vor diesem Saloon-Tür in den Supermarktbereich ist. Das heißt, die Leute stehen wirklich mit der linken Hüfte direkt an dieser Tür, wo man in den Supermarktbereich kommt, und die Leute wirklich mit einem, sorry, Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung, mit ihrem Wagen ständig an denen vorbei müssen. Und nicht einmal denkt sich einer dieser Leute, sag mal, vielleicht stehe ich ja komplett im Weg. Ja, aber ich verstehe. Komisch, dass die Leute sich an mir vorbeidrängen. Und ich bin wirklich, ich versuche der Wellenbrecher zu sein. Wenn ich sehe, die stellen sich im 90-Grad-Winkel, versuche ich mich wiederum im 90-Grad-Winkel anzustellen und so offensiv wie es geht, so dass die andere Person sich auch denkt, sag mal so, einfach um denen zu zeigen, denkt mal bitte kurz nach, wie ihr steht. Und da bin ich mittlerweile kurz davor zu sagen, Entschuldigung, schauen Sie sich einmal kurz um, meinen Sie nicht, Sie stehen im Weg. Also da bin ich noch nicht, sag ich auch nicht, da bin ich noch nicht.
Da brauche ich noch ein paar Werte. Ich glaube nämlich, die meisten wissen das, die meisten wissen das.
Nein, glaube ich eben nicht. Jeder Mensch, wenn man ein Diagramm von dieser Situation zeigen würde und einkreisen würde mit dem Kugelschreiber, das bist du, kannst du dir Dinge vorstellen, die du anders machen könntest, würde jeder
Mensch dieser Welt sagen, ja klar, natürlich,
ich stehe den ja im Weg, ich müsste mich eigentlich entlang
der Theke hinstellen. Genau, alle wissen das.
Aber sie machen es nicht, weil sie nicht dran denken.
Doch, nein, nein, ich glaube, es ist anders,
ich glaube, es ist komplexer. Ich glaube, weil ich würde mich
da auch anstellen, aber weil ich hätte
Angst. Ich hasse dich. Ja, aber ich komme ja nie dran,
wenn ich mich woanders anstelle.
Du kannst, das Kind ist in den Brunnen gefallen.
An dem Tag,
du kannst die zweite Person
Vielen Dank. Ja, aber ich komme ja nie dran, wenn ich mich voran das anstelle. Du kannst, das Kind ist in den Brunnen gefallen. An dem Tag, du kannst die zweite Person, die den Fehler begeht, die macht den Fehler. Das ist genau wie, wenn morgens im Ruhrteil gesprochen wird. Das haben wir immer schon so gemacht, das ist keine moralische Position. Weil da kannst du sagen, du wiederholst den Fehler des Vorgängers. Du hast die moralische Pflicht, es besser zu machen. Aber doch nicht, wenn dann dein Tag daraus besteht, drei Stunden beim fucking Heine-Mann anzustehen, weil du ein Dreckscroissant willst. Aber sonst passiert nie die Besserung. Weil du kannst ja, stell dir mal vor, so eine Schlange, wenn du die einmal gepolt hast, dann kann die ja noch stundenlang so weiterlaufen, weil es kommt ja immer jemand hin und führt die Struktur der Schlange vor. Du kannst so einen positiven Einfluss auf den Tag von so vielen Menschen haben, wenn du dich einmal unangenehm dann so neben die Person stellst. Du kannst es... Deswegen bist du ein Held. Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht bin ich auch einfach nur ein Arschloch. Und vielleicht habe ich zu viel Spaß daran, den Leuten vor die Augen zu führen, wie dumm sie sind. Es ist genau das Thema. Dann nimm doch bitte Krepppapier. Würde ich so gern.
Und dann mach doch einfach eine Linie.
Mach doch einfach schön eine Linie.
Das ist sogar seit Corona sind da
diese Dinge, und die sind genau wie sie sein sollen
mit dem Abstandhalter. Das wollte ich gerade sagen.
Trotzdem im Riener sein. Was ich gerne machen würde,
ich würde mir gerne so eine Fantasieuniform
zusammenstellen und in dieser
Fantasieuniform durch die Stadt gehen und Leute so wirklich, Entschuldigung, einmal bitte zur Seite, links, Entschuldigung, und die Leute so sortieren, am Bahnhof. So ein gesellschaftlicher Verbesserer. Genau, und ich glaube, die Leute, allein wenn man eine Uniform trägt, die kann komplett Fantasie sein, ich glaube, die Leute sagen, ah, okay, sorry, Entschuldigung. Okay, GVB, gesellschaftlicher Verbesserer. Gesellschaftsverbesserer. Gesellschaftsordner, go. Ich bin der GO von Hamburg. Hallo, ich bin von der GO. Genau. Wie sieht die Uniform aus? Ich finde gut, oben so eine Larry-David-Frisur. Ja. Wir müssen Larry-David damit. Eine Hommage. Also ich bin ja großer Fan, bin ich jetzt vielleicht der einzige, aber ich finde ja Piloten immer recht schneidig. Also ich denke jetzt eher so eine, oder so eine Kapitäns. An Sterne oben oder denkst du an Striche? Kordeln, nee, Kordeln. So wie so ein Admiral und so goldene Knöpfe, so ein großer Mantel. Ein Gehstock. Genau, so ein Schlagstock für die Polizei, dass sie das so ordnen. Gehstock. Okay, aber zur Not. Ich muss auch eine gewisse Gewaltbenis haben. Ja, Taser, das sind ein Taser, der aber nicht funktioniert. Die Batterien habe ich ausgenommen. Der aber so aussieht wie eine Pistole einfach mit so einem Griff, so an der Seite. Und ich glaube, also es gibt ja den Strafbestand der Amtsanmassung. Es ist verboten, so zu tun, als hätte man ein Amt inne von Polizei oder so. Aber was ist, wenn es... Wir haben alle Prinz Friedrich von Homburg. Nee, Hauptmann von Köpen nicht gewesen. gewesen. Aber was ist denn, wenn es das Amt, das ich mir anmasse, gar nicht wirklich gibt? Also wenn ich gar nicht sage, ich bin Polizist, sondern ich bin der GO, und das gibt es gar nicht. Ist es dann auch Amtsanmassung, wenn ich mir selber ein Amt ausdenke und sage, Entschuldigung, ich bin der GO von diesem Stadtteil hier, Entschuldigung, Sie stellen sich mal bitte hier in die Reihe, hier so entlang, schauen Sie, da stehen Sie den Leuten im Weg, schönen Tag noch. Ist das ein Strafbestand? Und dann würde ich an die, ich teste dich mal kurz als Gesellschaftsordner. Ja. Ich bin jetzt die nächste Person bei einer Eisdiele und ich komme dran. Ich komme dran, ich stand schon sehr lange an. Wie standen Sie dran? Ich stand gut an, okay, richtig, in einem richtigen Winkel und so, habe nieigen Winkel. Jetzt komme ich dran. Ja. Ah, was haben Sie denn Schönes? Mal gucken, was Sie... So, Sportsfreunde, jetzt passen wir alle mal auf. So, dieser Herr hier stand gerade zwölf Minuten lang in der Schlange. Ich will kurz mein Eis bestellen. Nein, Sie passellen. Nein, Entschuldigung, nee, nee, Sie passen jetzt mal auf. Aber freuen Sie mich an.
Ich habe einen Taser und ich bin bereit, ihn zu benutzen.
Dann weisen Sie sich wieder aus.
Ja, gerne, hier ist meine Marke.
Hier ist meine Marke.
G.O., was soll das bedeuten?
Gesellschaftsordner.
Sag mal, haben wir ein Problem jetzt gerade?
Soll ich Sie ordnen?
Na, ich glaube nicht, dass ich ordnet werden muss.
Natürlich, hier ist mein Ausweis.
Sie standen jetzt die ganze Zeit an, hatten die Möglichkeit, sich die Sorten anzuschauen
und jetzt überlegen Sie, wenn Sie dran sind, was glauben sie denn, was es für Eiscremesorten gibt? Wahrscheinlich die gängigen. Wahrscheinlich die gängigen. Und welche nehmen sie am Ende eh immer? Haselnuss Zitrone. Na also, nehmen sie Haselnuss Zitrone. So, ich will jetzt hier vom Kein mehr sehen, dass man erst überlegt, wenn man dran ist. So, weitermachen. Hopp, hopp! Oh, das wird mir so viel Spaß. Ja, kann ich auch mit Karte zahlen?
Ah, ich habe's auch noch klein. Nee, ruhig mit Karte, ist auch okay. Wie viele Münzen sind das? Wir nehmen keine Karte an, wir nehmen keine Karte an. Gut, okay. Zu Ihnen komme ich gleich, zu Ihnen komme ich gleich. Ich hab's auch klein. Ähm, hier, aber ganz klein, ui. Nein, nichts unter 20 Cent, nichts unter 20 Cent. Stopp, so, und jetzt gibt's die gelbe Karte. Jetzt gibt's die gelbe Karte. Spannend, spannend. Was passiert bei der roten Karte? Taser. Ich werde nicht getasert, und wo komme ich hin? Wo du landest halt. Ach so, und dann bleib ich am Boden liegen. Du bleibst ja, ist mir egal. Das ist mein Problem. Du bringst mich ane ich mich an so einem Ort, wo man wieder gerade ... Wir haben leider keine Kapazitäten. Das GO-Amt ist recht unterbesetzt. Ich dachte, es ist deine Privatwohnung, wo du uns wie so ein Dummy-Test ... Wo du zwischen den Poolnudeln dann im Gefängnis landest. Nee, nicht Gefängnis, aber so einen Idiotentest machen musst, um in der Gesellschaft wieder reinzukommen. Ja, auch nicht schlecht. Ich hätte da so Lust drauf. Wir tun uns zusammen. Falls Leute Bock drauf haben, meldet euch. Vielleicht gibt es irgendeinen Uniform-Designer. Seid ihr Modedesigner, Designerin oder so was? Wir brauchen eine Geste eigentlich. Wir brauchen eine Geste, wir brauchen eine Pfeife, wir brauchen eine komplette Uniformierung, wir brauchen ein Wappensymbol und eine Uniform. Und dann gibt es, es ist ein freiwilliges Amt, es ist ein Ehrenamt. Es ist ein Ehrenamt, es ist ein freiwilliges Amt. Ich meine, es braucht es, das ist der Punkt, von dem ich verstehe, wir brauchen sowas. Ja, jeder Bahnhof, jeder große Bahnhof braucht sowas und dann halt wirklich so eine Streife und vor allem dann, stell dir das mal vor, es gibt eine Art Notruf, du kannst anrufen und du kannst den GO von Hamburg rufen und dann kommt der und im Kino oder so oder wo auch immer du bist, kommt der dann und scheißt die Leute zusammen, die sich falsch verhalten. Es ist wirklich wie ein Notruf. Du kannst die Leute rufen und dann kommt der GO und kommt halt an und sagt hier, so Freunde, schauen wir uns das Ganze mal an. Ja genau genau also ich bin hier in dieser Kneipe gewesen und ganz aufgebracht sind die leute auch draußen stehen also mit so einem Notizblock und ich habe schon so eine diese goldene Panikdecke die hast du mir umgelegt so eine heiße Thermoskandendeckel die hast du mir umgelegt so jetzt beruhigen sich erstmal alles in Ord Erzählen Sie mal ganz ruhig, was passiert ist. Genau, ich habe mit den ganzen Freunden hier in der Bar und wir haben den ganzen Tag getrunken, Abend getrunken. Jetzt habe ich mich noch ganz aufgeregt. Ganz ruhig, beruhige ich sich, alles ist gut. Genau, am Ende wollte ich gerne mit Karte zahlen, wie es ja inzwischen Gang und Gäbe ist. Und Sie haben einfach kein Kartengerät hier. Wer hat, können Sie sich noch genau an die Person erinnern, der hinten steht? Bei Ihrer Kollegin, der von Ihrer Kollegin zurückgehalten wird. Okay, alles klar, und Sie sind sich sicher, dass er gesagt hat, es gibt keine Karten. Das war, er hat gesagt, wir können hier nicht mit Karte zahlen, es geht nur bar. Aber es steht nirgendwo. Es war nicht angeschrieben. Nein, da habe ich gesagt, da musste ich jetzt endlich irgendwie zwei Minuten nach hinten, zu dem man an Bankautomaten laufen können und so. Und dann zahlt man auch irgendwie noch vier Euro oder sowas Bankgebühr drauf. Machen Sie sich keine Sorgen. Und deswegen habe ich dann Sie angerufen sofort und danke, dass Sie so schnell kommen konnten. Kein Problem. Ich höre Ihre Probleme, ich werde mich darum kümmern. Danke, dass Sie, weil es Weihnachten, danke, dass Sie Weihnachten darüber rauskommen. Natürlich, jederzeit, jederzeit. Die Gesellschaft muss geordnet werden. Ich meine, es ist 22 Uhr am 24. Habe ich Sie jetzt zu Hause erwischt oder so? Egal wann. Warten Sie die ganze Zeit auf Anrufe. Natürlich, egal wann. Haben Sie heute viel zu tun wahrscheinlich. Richtig viel zu tun, aber wir kümmern uns drum. So, Sie haben nicht angeschrieben, dass der Kartenautomateffekt ist, oder wie? Bei uns kann man einfach nicht mit Karte zahlen. Taser! Holy shit! Bum bumm, Taser in die Fresse, Taser ins Auge. Ich meine, da ist es dann vielleicht schon Körperverletzung, aber da muss man drüber reden. Es ist eine Art von Selbstverteidigung, vielleicht kann man auf Selbstverteidigung. Also eine Art gesellschaftliche Ordnung. Wie ich denn so mein lässiges Leben lebe draußen und es ist nicht alles richtig, aber es ist einfach convenient. Und dann sehe ich dich hinten mit so einer Warnweste schon am Auto stehen. Parkw Hand halte ich meinen Helm, mit der anderen Hand meinen Gestock, wette ich so, stillgestanden, stillgestanden! Und du bist schon komplett heiser. Es ist irgendwie neun Uhr morgens, so lange kannst du noch nicht unterwegs sein. Du siehst aus, hättest du nicht geschlafen, du bist schon mega heiser, du schwitzt total, du kommst keine zwei Meter weit, überall bist du am Gestikulieren, ich höre dich noch gar nicht, aber ich sehe wilde Gestiken und deinen Helm, den du festhältst, während du Leuten hinterherläufst, die dich abhängen, Kinder rennen. Locker abhängen. Mit Kinderwagen hängen die dich locker ab. Das würde ich gerne machen. Und dann brauchen wir so einen Dienstplan. Oh, ich stelle so eine richtige Behörde auf. Ich stampfe das richtig aus dem Boden.
GO. Gesellschaftsordner. In jeder Stadt
Gesellschaftsordner. Und dann brauchen
wir wirklich so Prinzipien, so Statuten.
Knigge, oder was?
Schon in diese Richtung.
Sowas in der Richtung, natürlich auch am Bahnhof.
Vor allem, du kannst dann, wenn du jemanden im Ruheabteil
hast, zum Beispiel... Non-legal
Regeln. Non-legal Gesellschaftsregeln. Ja, es gibt ja NGO, Non-Government, wir bräuchten so eine Non-Government-Behörde. So eine Behörde, die aber nicht Teil des Staatsapparats ist. Nee, weil es geht auch nicht um Exekutive im juristischen Sinne, sondern es sind ja Dinge, die erlaubt sind. Ich darf mich ja wirklich hinstellen an der Bäckerei. Wir sind eine außerjuristische Behörde. Genau. Wir machen unser eigenes Gesetz. Und dann kannst du zum Beispiel, wenn du jemanden... Da wird es dann halt auch schwierig und antidemokratisch. Du kannst doch ein Gesetz, du kannst doch ein paralleles Gesetz. Das meine ich. Niemand verbietet dir ein zweites Gesetz zu haben. Im Gesetz steht, das ist meine Idee. Also BGB, Paragraph 1 ist, Leute, ich habe hier mal was aufgeschrieben. Wenn ihr eine bessere Idee habt, jederzeit, bis dahin können wir erst mal machen, wie ich mir gerade das vorgestellt habe. Paragraph 1, die Würde des Menschen ist unantastbar, es sei denn im Ruheabteil. Und dann kommt einfach die andere. Genau, es sei denn, Paragraph 2. Und zum Beispiel, wenn du jemanden im Ruheabteil hast, der laut ist, kannst du so, okay, gleich fahren wir in Hagen ein, dann kannst du Geo-Antrag stellen auf der Webseite, gibt es ein Geo in Hagen und der fährt dann zum Bahnhof, steigt kurz ein, sagt, Entschuldigung, das ist das Ruheabteil, das sind die ganze Zeit schon laut, steigt wieder aus und muss gar nicht mitfahren, sondern der kann dann direkt da eingreifen. Gut, jetzt hast du dich primär auf diese beiden Probleme fokussiert. Schlangen?
Schlangen beim Back... nein, nein, es war nicht Schlangen, es waren Schlangen beim Bäcker in Supermärkten und das Thema, was wir schon ein paar Mal gehört haben, was sich jetzt ein bisschen durchzieht und noch ein bisschen sich ermüdend wirkt langsam. Als kleine Behörde können wir uns nur um wenige Probleme kommen. Wer weiß, ob wir expandieren? Wer weiß, expandieren? Ich, ich, der einzige andere im Raum. Der einzige andere Mensch im Raum weiss schon, dass er nicht expandiert. Wir haben das Ruheteilreferat, wir haben das Kinoreferat, wir haben Unterbehörden, wir haben verschiedene Botengänge, wir haben verschiedene Strukturen, sodass wirklich die gesamte Gesellschaft abgedeckt werden kann. Ich glaube, das ist machbar. Ich glaube, das ist wirklich machbar. Ich glaube, ihr werdet durch die Städte gejagt mit Fackeln und Heugrabeln. Vor allem, du hast dann auch so ... Und jetzt kümmert ihr euch um die Gesellschaft, denk ich dann, als Außenstehender, dass die Leute mit Fackeln und Heugrabeln euch niederwetzen, weil dann plötzlich werden sie aktiv. Hätten sie aber vorher an der Schlange ... Ich bin ja auf eurer Seite, aber Sie sich ja vorher eine Schlange mal überlegen können, wie eine Gesellschaft besser wird. Wichtig, aber vor allem unser wichtigstes Anliegen ist natürlich auch Aufklärung. Also du erinnerst dich vielleicht Joker, Joaquin Phoenix, der Film, wo der immer so dann auch so laminierte Karten hat. I'm a Joker, I'm a Broker, I'm a real life dog. Das war der Soundtrack, das kam so häufig vor im Film. Weiß ich gar nicht, bin ich mir gar nicht sicher, ehrlich gesagt. War es nicht 500 recht viel? Ja, auch recht viel. Und der hat ja immer diese laminierte Karte, weil er so Lachanfälle hat in der Öffentlichkeit. Und dann gibt er denen die Karte so irgendwie auch so Tourette-mäßig dann so, bitte denken Sie sich nicht dabei, das ist einfach meine Condition. Und genau solche laminierten Karten bräuchte man auch, die genormt sind. Für dich, das ist einfach meine Condition. Es tut mir leid, dass ich jetzt so lehrerhaft. Einerseits auch, aber andererseits, dass wenn man jemanden in der Bäckereischlange fertig gemacht hat, denen auch so eine Karte gibt, so einen Flyer, so, ah, sie stehen also im Weg. Und dann so eine Frau, die so auf ihren ... Stockfoodisch-Frau, die so ihr Leben hinterfragt. Ja, ah, sie sind also ein Arschloch, wie geht's weiter? So, und dann gibt's so ... Hinten Notfallnummern. Notfallnummern, ja. Ah, Sie stehen also bei der Rolltreppe im Weg. Wie ist ein Leben überhaupt noch möglich? So Selbsthilfe-Flyer. Unzivilisiertes Verhalten ablegen und dann einfach die 116 116 anrufen. Es muss so nicht weitergehen. Und da in dem Flyer stehen dann hilfreiche Tipps, wie man sich in der Gesellschaft besser verwendet. Gucken, wo stehe ich? Stehe ich in Fluchtwegen? Stehe ich Leuten im Weg? Und diese genormten Flyer kann man sich auch bestellen, weil wir haben natürlich ein riesiges Spitzelnetz über ganz Deutschland. Oh, ich hasse diese. Nicht nur die Uniformierten, eigentlich die Zivilagenten sind die wichtigsten. Stasi, das ist eigentlich Stasi. Es ist eine Art Stasi, ja. Und die können dann nämlich diese Flyer dann so, auch du parkst Scheiße und sowas, gibt es dann verschiedene Flyer zu verschiedenen Anlässen und die kann man dann den Leuten aushändigen. Ich hätte mal einen Zettel an meiner Windschutzscheibe. Da standen drei Wörter drauf, die mich nachhaltig geprägt. Parken noch lernen. Prägnant, scharf, Messerscharf, zack, unter die Windschutzscheibe. Hei, da geht mir mein GO-Herz auf. Oder die Druckerei noch lernen. Wir haben eine eigene Druckerei, eine Behördendruckerei, wo genau solche Karten hergestellt. Aber das ist zum Beispiel genau der Unterschied zwischen Arschlöchern und der GO. Weil die GO würde nicht einfach nur sagen, du parkst falsch, sondern da wäre ein Diagramm drauf, wo präzise erklärt wird, warum du so schlecht parkst, was du besser machen kannst und wirklich mit so einem Selbsthilfeding so, hey, wir waren alle mal an dem Punkt, wo wir uns keine Gedanken gemacht haben. Und so Videos, so schlecht produzierte Videos, wie dann so eine Frau, weil man steht ein bisschen auf dem Gehweg vielleicht, man sieht mal hinten so eine Frau mit Kinderwagen, der nicht durchkommt und man so mit Anlauf, das ist doch völlig überinszeniert, die so mit Anlauf versucht. Das Kind fliegt so aus dem Kinderwagen raus, sie schreit und sie schreit und wirft die Hände in die Höhe. Man sieht diese kleine Puppe, die in dem Kinderwagen sitzt, so ein Dummy mit diesem Kreis, auch diesen schwarzen. Ja, und das Gehirn so im Kopf des Kindes schwappt hin und her. Aber dann, diese Animation ist weirdly good, man sieht so, alles Geld ist in diese Animation von diesem Gehirn geflossen, von diesem Kleinkind, so ein Zoom in das Gehirn, das wackelt und so, und dann sieht man und das Kind fliegt vorne raus und dann so, das können sie verhindern. 20 Jahre später und das Kind, das parkt wieder so schlecht. Lassen Sie Ihr Kind nicht auch zum Falschparker werden, greifen Sie jetzt ein. 116, 116. das wäre fantastisch. Ich glaube wirklich, also wenn sich Leute melden, es gibt bestimmt genug Spitzle und Spürnasen. Ich glaube, dieses Denunziantentum, das natürlich... Ich finde gut, dass du beim Spitzel, bei dem Wortspitzen nicht mehr versuchst, das sympathisch zu konnotieren. Nee, ich rede von Denunzianten. Ich glaube einfach, dass die in der, gerade in der deutschen Geschichte einfach auch viel negativ besetzt wird, diese Denunziantenkraft, die ja da ist in der Bevölkerung, wenn man die schafft,
die positiv, konstruktiv
einzusetzen. So wie es die schlafenden Riesen-Denunziantenkraft
Deutschland wecken. Oh, die schlafen nicht, die sind hellwach.
Die Frage ist nur, wer kann sie leiten?
Puh, puh, puh, puh, puh.
Falls, also wir brauchen erstmal Uniformen. Falls ihr
Designer, Designerin seid, meldet euch.
Hugo Boss, hey, Boss, wie falls du...
Schöne, so schwarze, schnittige Anzüge
für die G.O., die dann mit so scharfen, so schönen, geschnittenen Hüten. Und ich meine, zur besseren Sichtbarkeit wäre natürlich Armbinden gut. Ein Emblem, rotes Emblem vielleicht. Ein Emblem, Armbinde, aber es muss halt auch klar sein, dass man nicht die Polizei ist. Gesellschafts-Nazis, sagen wir doch, wie es ist. Ich finde, du bist einfach nicht visionär genug, um mal auch eine gute Idee feststellen zu können. Haltet die Augen auf, ob bei euch in der Strasse jetzt irgendwo ein Büro auftaucht und ihr zu spitzeln werdet. Ich glaube, wir können die Gesellschaft verletzen. Die G.O. Kommt dann an mit so einem Mietwagen immer. Mit so einem Blaulicht oben drauf. Ja, mit so Car2Gos. Die Fenster schnallen nach unten und sie schreien dich an mit ... Sie machen das wahrscheinlich nicht so häufig, aber ... Sie haben sich wahrscheinlich noch nie in eine Schlange angestellt, das merkt man. Das merkt man. Ach, achtet drauf, ansonsten wünschen wir euch ... Schaut doch, dass ihr es zumindest besser macht, und dann sehen wir uns nächste Woche wieder. Bis dahin, haut rein. Oder gibt Leuten einfach nette Tipps und seid nicht so gut. Ja, oder vielleicht sagt auch einfach gar nichts, ärgert euch rein und schluckt den Ärger einfach runter.
Genau, bis ihr irgendwann platzt und ein zum Opfer dieser Gesellschaft wurde.
Alles klar, macht's gut und noch eine schöne Woche, wir heben ab.
Tschau!